good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Wednesday it is
hump day here at the toast a gorgeous
beautiful fine day we love hump day hump
day hump I am joined in Studio by you
know very appropriately someone whom I
wouldn't mind I take advantage of Hump
Day EXA every every day is hump day in
our home every day is hump day I'm
joined in Studio by Ben saer jacn fle
has fallen ill and you know she trudged
she got through two shows this week but
we gave her today off she's really not
doing well so Ben is here instead which
is honestly so appropriate why is that
okay so you don't listen to the show
thanks yesterday on the show we had a
conversation like about free will let me
just ask you Ben do you think we have
free will I do you do I do yes so I was
saying like what's stopping one of us
from just like
quitting um that's a great question uh
letting others down of course the
consequences it's yeah but they're all
all these things are emotional you could
easily quit so what we had said was that
like if one of us quit who would we
replace the other with and so I my
answer was obviously you yes Jackie had
said she'd hold auditions between olivan
Marco Who ah who cut it interesting
interesting so she didn't say me no she
didn't say you why would you expect her
to no I mean I just won't be filling in
for her anymore so Jackie if you'd like
Olivia and Margo then whenever you fall
ill fall ill uh you can call them you
can arrange their travel it's so funny
how you like took that as an insult
because it was really like a nice
conversation it was I don't see it that
way oh my God you're so like such victim
mentality I don't see it that way I
chose you I know as you should because I
am the obvious choice but it's fine it
is what it is wow you're kind of getting
like a bit of a big head you're looking
pretty great in that hat speaking of big
head thank you you know oh we're both
wearing hats I mean you always wear a
hat on no I you say I don't listen but I
know that we're in our hat era okay so
you watch the clips on Instagram we
talked about hats on the clips that's
why it's true I can always tell when
somebody references toast moments that
only were made into Clips I'm like oh so
you don't listen to the podcast you just
watch the clips which totally counts we
appreciate the engagement and at any you
know in any way it is a great hat I got
it at a Drake concert I know and you're
wearing a hat too I am wearing a hat
it's our you always wear a hat it's our
new Good Guys merch so yeah let's talk
about that yeah so you're kind of like
uh oh my god did anybody hear that yeah
I thought literally we were being robbed
I think somebody like UPS just dropped
off a package but they must have thrown
it at our door yeah that was crazy with
the no my heart just stopped are we just
still running yeah we're still running
okay so um UPS definitely took an entire
box and chucked it at the door like they
didn't place it on the floor they like
one two let's do we can break three no
yeah that was terrifying cuz that's the
sound of like somebody coming to kill
you no that was very scary oh my God but
we're fine we're F we're all good all
good in the hood
settle yourself merch well yeah I wanted
to talk to you because clearly you have
a big head um and I think that comes
from the success of your your personal
podcast it does it does you know every
time you're here the podcast gets bigger
and bigger you and Josh have just been
killing it thank you darling um so yeah
like go off I love it it's just so fun
and to any toasters that aren't
listening I think you're just like being
a little stubborn like it's a really
really great maybe they're just being
loyal you would really no you can listen
to both like you can listen to both it's
one it's one week like we're just
basically giving you a bonus app it's
true it be part of patreon yeah it's a
bonus app it's just just extra we have
so many amaz you call it now yeah bonus
EP such amazing guests like Josh and I
we do the solo episodes those are
amazing but then the guests this week or
uh in two weeks Christ Stephano yeah
it's cuz like your co-host is an actual
celebrity who like Knows by the way when
did I I take the handouts I'm not saying
that we like I wasn't attacking you I'm
just saying that's why you have an amaz
amazing gu no we have amazing guests
because we have an amazing show yeah no
of course of course now there's kind of
like a controversy in your community
that I think we should address tell
me where in the world is Miranda
Cosgrove's episode yes it's coming um so
because of sag you guys recorded an
episode with Miranda Cosgrove who of
course played Megan and Drake and Josh
that's like an iconic moment in pop
culture it's going to break the internet
when it comes out you don't stop talking
about this episode you recorded it and
it never came out I know um because of
sag sag ruined everybody's lives and
like the fact is like as a member of sag
you're not a member of sag I'm really
really happy that I fought with my
brothers and sisters to get us the right
contract by the way you're not a member
of sag but you were a sag compliant
podcast I was we were we were completely
you followed all the rules we were
completely we followed all the rules and
we spoke too much about future projects
current projects past projects with
Miranda Miranda that we couldn't air it
but Miranda's episode will be a
Christmas gift it will definitely air
sometime in December okay famous last
words it's like give the people what
they want where where's Miranda costro I
promise it's coming promise there's like
a conspiracy theory that like oh is
maybe you never recorded it maybe you
guys were lying are people really
talking oh you're making it up but every
time the good guys like gets talked
about like in our comment section people
are like where is Miranda cosgro got it
it's coming it was sag I'm sorry also
like that episode was recorded so long
ago and I know that the podcast is just
better so like I hope the episode is
still good it is it is don't be so hard
on yourself that's how you know you're a
true podcaster constantly for greatness
it's true we are well I'm so proud of
you and Josh thank you darling we need
to have you back on the show I'm on all
the time our you were on once and the
episode was amazing um excuse me I was
on twice when was the first time when
you first launched it doesn't count you
were on once and it was amazing by the
way do you see how uh black uh blue my
shoe is here yeah so uh Nike I found out
has a 30-day return policy we're on day
29 so I'm going to take these puppies in
shop them out Ben Sofer he will be
reading the fine print of the return
policy I've never seen anyone make
returns quite like Ben I saw him return
a pair of pants I'm not gonna say the
store because I don't want to get you in
trouble that literally you wore like the
entire time we dated for years and they
had a hole in the crotch and you
literally return them yeah it did what's
your secret uh what's my secret you know
just and where did you learn if you
don't try it's true all they they could
say no what's the worst thing what's the
worst thing that can happen and where
did you get that sort of tenacity I once
watched my father return 25-year-old
Gucci loafers what what I once watched
him return them and I don't know and the
person took him and he got new ones were
they worn were they worn they were worn
for 25 years these are the oldest shoes
these are like his grandfather's shoes
That's So Brucey yeah so like I don't
make I'm making it seem like I make
returns or we're making it seem like I
make returns quite of you never do don't
I never do just because I'm too lazy but
when I do when you put your mind to
something when I put my mind to
something I can do it so I'm going to
return these bad boys because this is
also just staining no that's a crap pair
of shoes just staining they didn't age
well in the 25 days 25 29 days let me
ask you another question was it
difficult growing up with a father named
Bruce why because of Matilda yes oh my
God how did you know I was going to say
that because uh it's iconic Bruce is
such an iconic name Brucey Bruce
Springstein Bruce Sofer Bruce Willis
Bruce Willis totally Bruce strong name
Bruce is a great name and it's even
though the people you just named aren't
it's a very Jewish name yes is Bruce
Springsteen Jewish he's just from New
Jersey what a question I don't think he
is I don't know the last name Steen yeah
but I don't think so no I don't think so
either because nothing about him is
Jewish except the fact that he's from
New Jersey and his name is Bruce yeah
yeah speaking of Jewish there was a
fabulous event in DC yesterday fabulous
over almost 300,000 people showed up in
DC to March against anti-Semitism it was
one of the most beautiful things I'd
ever seen in my life and I had so much
[__] fomo it looked incredible I just
want to say yeser kak to everybody who
went it was a beautiful to Sea of blue
it was really it was stunning and I was
very proud to be Jewish yes me too
always proud to be Jewish but yesterday
was a was a great day and I do wish that
we went and uh just from the videos it
looked like there was like such like a
great concert like Omar Adam who just
like has been unbelievable Omar Adam is
basically like the Taylor Swift of
Israel he's the biggest star ever youve
probably like actually heard some of his
music here in America cuz it's it gets
so popular yeah you wouldn't know that
you know him he was there but you should
look him up if you he's saying the
national anthem oh my God it was
chilling Matisyahu was there a legend
love him one day
one
one one day one day you should become
like a Jewish Orthodox rapper I could do
it I know you love niss black love him
he he does music right yeah you should
do it he's great I'm down why not just
add it to my repertoire totally add it
to my Rolodex well your repertoire today
and your Rolodex today is very busy
because we have five stories that are
all very good let's go we have some sad
news we have some TV news we have some
cheek crack hole
news and then we have dear toaster
whichc you always Crush yeah um we also
have a similar segment on my podcast at
speak pipe for good guys so if in case
you ever have a maybe they're not
answering you you know you're like
submitting dear toer dear toer why is
CLA ignoring me we won't ignore
we will respond CU you get so few
submissions we will respond we have the
time right cuz you get so few
submissions that you can answer every
single one that comes in meanwhile we
get thousands of people dying to help us
we can only help so many corre so go to
speak pipe.com Goodguys to submit and we
your voices will be heard if you like
keep over promoting me like you're not
going to be asked back you won't be my
fing co-host when Jackie quits one day
what no I'm kidding I have to I speaking
of promotion I did want to say one thing
oh we are closing pre-orders for the
chili season merch tonight night so
every size is available we're going to
close it tonight so we can start
shipping out orders and getting getting
the sweaters made so shop toast
merch.com for the chili season hoodies
crew necks and hats it's closing tonight
thank you to everyone who purchased I
can't wait for you all to get it so we
can just like cuddle up on a Sunday with
our chili and our chili season merch
that's shop toast merch.com and the
merch is actually unbelievable unreal So
Soft delicious pillowy oh so now you're
taking my advice where I said you were
over promoting yourself too much and now
you're channeling that energy towards
promoting Myself by the way I don't over
promote myself myself too much I over
promote everything your projects no I
over promote you you do nobody over
promotes you more than me it's true no
one over promotes you more than me you
don't want me to promote myself I'll
stop promoting in general I'll stop
promoting in general I'll stop promoting
I'll stop promoting I'll stop promoting
what do you think of this sweater I
think it's nice I think you look great
thank you so much do you want to tell
everyone have you spoken on good guys
about how you're aoic uh
we might have briefly I have been off
OIC though for six weeks now how's it
going it's going well I've recently
started a fitness journey um I will say
and this is not a plug uh I'm taking
athletic greens every morning and it's
really I'm like so freaking awake I told
everyone on the toast yesterday cuz ag1
was a sponsor I'm I'm loving it I'm
loving it and I think that that's really
helping I'm going to the gym that said
like what OIC is really good at doing is
quieting the brain at night where it's
like hey tubby stop eating stop eating
so that thought is now gone so I'm
having trouble again from the 900 p.m.
to 12 a.m. time slot which many of you
may be able to relate to and if you you
know [__] is off the rails when Ben
walks into the room with his nerds robe
like yeah no what nerds clusters that's
Ben's like everybody has their thing
like they'll like for me it's an
entiments chocolate chip cookie like I
don't care if I'm on like death store if
you offer me an timent chocolate chip
cookie like I will eat the whole box
that's my thing your thing very weirdly
cuz it's not even like Savory or good is
nerd clusters yeah the Nerds clusters
are really good ice cream is really good
and the problem is I can't have a spoon
of ice cream I have a pint and I can't
have a gummy cluster I have a bag so I
need to stop bringing the stuff into the
home that's what I told you I know I
know every time Ben ERS a gopuff like we
know we're in trouble I know I order
like 9,000 things on gopuff shout out
gopuff so all in all how would you
describe the post o because that's what
everybody wants to know it's great look
it's completely doable I'm up I'm up one
pound in six weeks and that's only
because I'm just not being mentally
strong enough but I can do it and I will
continue to lose weight post ozempic I'm
in the gym I'm feeling so much better
everybody knows my fitness journey is
the sto method like I'm very loyal to
the sto method I don't I don't try like
a bunch of different I'm not the type of
girl like I need to do one manageable
workout and like I really like the soo
method what are you doing I'm doing the
live method oh of course same as Margot
uh Matt owns the gym he's my trainer and
it is he's the best just he expains it
TOS like it he me like the uh chemistry
it and why we're doing certain things
over other things and we're really we're
working on stretching me out like making
me longer cuz I'm so tight we're also
strengthening my big toe I didn't know I
had a weak big toe but that's why I'm a
little bit pigeon toed because I if if
this trainer can fix your pigeon toed
and I am not always tripping over your
[__] feet yeah I swear to God I will
get that man a key to the city if he can
fix that I will do anything he wants how
you going to get a key to the city
that's the thing I'll be don't make PR
I'll be so passionate you make promises
you can't keep oh please honey Dijon
bath like a decade old who brings it
back up okay let's talk about that
anybody who listens to the show I know
we always have like so many new
listeners so you might not know some of
the history but today we're going to
explain but OG girlies will
remember that Ben made a promise on the
internet what was the goal you needed
one decade ago you needed to achieve it
was 100,000 likes on this post Ben said
if he got 100,000 likes on this post he
would a different Instagram he would
take a bath but instead of water it
would be honey
mustard feasibly it just doesn't there
there was no way to do it I never
intended not to do it I just want to let
you all know that does not I would do it
right so no by the way where the I would
give a key to the city okay fine totally
if I could do it God I can't throw bull
I can't I can't shoot buet if I'm not
willing ready to take them those in
glass houses shouldn't throw stones God
my God okay you're right you're 100%
right thank give him a key to the city
no I'm just saying I didn't know that
like you your toe thing had anything to
do with you maybe not being in the best
shape yeah so it it just I'm relying too
much on the front pad of my foot not
enough on the toe the toe is what keeps
it in a straight line balanced Bal so
working on my balance uh we're doing
some deadlifts we're doing some we're
really strength training so watch out
folks no I love that I'm hoping to get a
little ripped I really like I think for
both of us like who've some people like
get into fitness like early on and it's
like a huge part of their life Fitness
becomes like so exclusive and it's very
hard it's unaccessible and I think it's
really hard to find like trainers or
programs that feel like they're good for
beginners because it's almost just like
an inner circle and it's like you have
to work hard to get in I think that the
key is and not enough people talk about
this when you're fat you don't have the
mental motivation to go to the gym no
there's so many elements especially as a
girl like you don't want to be in tight
clothes in front of people you don't
want to do a class cuz you can't keep up
and you feel embarrassed but what
everybody wants you to do is go hard in
the gym and eat really well I'm telling
you the key eat really well for 6 months
go on on zic don't go on O zic whatever
you want to do lose 30 lbs just eating
and then try going to the gym and it
will be so much easier mentally
physically emotionally the idea of going
to the gym when you're at your fattest
is is not the right way to get somebody
to stay in the gym it would be great and
sometimes I think like damn I wish I
started going to the gym when I started
my whole Health Journey which was a year
ago and I only started going to the gym
like four months ago um but I just I
know that was never like that's not a
possibility for me like I was so like
unhappy in my body and I was so
embarrassed like I don't think I would
have been able to do five minutes on the
treadmill it's also just hard it would
have been disheartening and discouraging
the moves would have been much harder
too of course that's what I'm saying you
know um okay so we actually like a lot
to do today we need to stop dilling
dallying Ben I have one question for you
are you ready for the fast five stories
that you need to know I'm ready but can
we play Beat the crunch okay come wait
let's get
okay are you ready for the fast five
stories that
you need to
know why aren't you going oh say a bite
out of your it's that's why we do crunch
oh wait what do we say oh here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you take a bite out of your
morning
toast I let you win I definitely beat it
what do you mean you let me win I let
you win by the way by the way I'm sorry
removing that was like removing a piece
of the toast soul I know but we we
aren't the morning toast anymore and
because the toast Soul has been removed
Listen to Good Guys it's just we
wouldn't do that to you if we had a
staple like beat the crew by the way
talk to me when been around for seven
years true true big truth this show that
is rooted in history is brought to you
by State Farm the State Farm personal
price plan helps you create an
affordable price just for you the plan's
all about being personal to you and your
needs and that means you're getting the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know you love to
personalize your entire day we're always
saying here with the toe so many things
are so personal comedy food poetry
insurance I mean what's more personal
than Insurance nothing speaking of I
know you saw me hanging out with Jake
from skate Farm did did you feel like
threatened in any sort of way I did
especially because he only comes at 3 in
the morning and he's really like a
celebrity I know we joke that you are
but he really is so joke that I am did
you feel threatened no I didn't feel
threatened I'm a legitimate celebrity we
hobnob me and him me and Jake are you
worried yeah about me and Jake no I'm
worried about me and Jake I was very Jak
he's going to come to me at 3: in the
morning and then you'll feel left out
personalization just makes everything
that much better State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage your selections can
all be personalized by you cuz think
about all the things in your life that
you care about your home your car your
family flooding wherever you live so
many things are so detailed and personal
to you and your life situation and State
Farm understands that so like a good
neighbor State Farm is there prices vary
by state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
let me try that one more time like a
good neighbor State Farm is
that's stunk like a neigh St Farm is
there no do it again
go okay today's episode is also brought
to you by Zach do have you ever been on
the hunt for a new doctor and you ask
literally everyone you know for the
recommendation you know a doctor who
actually listens to you listens who
understands you and makes you feel very
comfortable well after finally weeks of
searching you find the one so you call
their office make an appointment but
then the receptionist tell you that the
doctor doesn't take your insurance so
Zach talk is is getting rid of like all
the torture of finding a new doctor
that's like a weird part of being older
nobody talks about like you need so many
different doctors for like different
things and where do you find doctors
especially doctors that don't have like
a six-month waiting list or doctors that
don't take your insurance that's where
Zach do comes in it's a free app where
you can find amazing doctors and book
appointments online we're talking about
booking appointments with thousands of
top rated patient review doctors and
Specialists you can filter specifically
for ones who take your insurance who are
located near you and treat almost any
condition you're searching for these
doctors have all verified reviews from
actual real patients they are not Bots
and the average weight time to see a
doctor booked on Zach do is between just
24 and 48 hours cuz sometimes you know M
for me when my tendonitis is AC not I
can't be wasting time waiting for a
doctor's appointment you can even score
same day appointments so once you find
the doctor you want you can book them
immediately with just a few TAPS in
their app no more waiting awkwardly on
hold with a receptionist Zach do was a
great resource when Jackie moved that's
one of the things you don't think about
when you move it's like I got to find
all new doctors so go to Zach do.com
toast and download the Zach do app for
free then find a book find and book a
top readed doctor today that's
zocdoc.com toast Zach
do.com
tzach do.com toast today's episode is
also brought to you by modern fertility
think back to sexed for a moment you
probably learned all about how to
prevent pregnancy but what about how to
plan for it we've always been big fans
of planning ahead you know scheduling
trips months in advance plotting our
next career moves figuring out what
we're doing for dinner while we're
having breakfast but if you've never
given much thought to planning for kids
that's what modern fertility is all
about it's an easy and affordable way to
test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple simple finger prick mail
it in with a prepaid label and you'll
get your personalized results within six
business days you'll get insight into
your hormone levels like your ovarian
reserve and other important factors that
can impact your fertility the results go
very deep into what every hormone means
and you could also download the results
to review with your doctor for next
steps traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over $600 most
of the time even more than that but
modern fertility tests the same general
set of hormones for only $179 and when
you go to Modern fertility.com toast you
can get $20 off your test also another
great benefit is that you can get
reimbursed for the test through your FSA
or your HSA so if you want kids today or
maybe one day in the future clinically
sound information about your body can
help you make the decision that's right
for you so right now modern fertility is
offering our listeners $20 off the test
when you go to Modern fertility.com
toast that means your test will cost
$159 it is a fraction of the cost of
what it would be at a fertility clinic
so get $20 off your fertility test when
you go go to Modern fertility.com toast
that's modern fertility.com
modern fertility.com toast all right
Benny you ready for these stories I am
quickly you'll notice that I'm wearing
my glasses and not wearing my context
and would you like to know why no but go
off King I ran out of contacts they gave
me a sample pack M right I went to800
contacts to order them thought that they
were ordered last week canceled my order
this morning out of the blue it's
disgusting I didn't even know why they
don't want you to see and now I have no
contacts and there's no way why can't I
walk into a store and get contacts why
is it so hard you can walk into a
glasses store where the [__] do people
buy contacts that's actually an amazing
call like the purchasing of contacts is
so
needlessly a guy like it's like a like
drugs totally like I I need my contact
dealer like whaty nuts it's a great it's
a great call that's a great Wy nuts
terrible okay ready for our stories in
no particular order there's no like one
big story today but they're all very
impactful hit me with them this first
one is devastating news tell me young
Sheldon will end with season 7 at CBS
the series finale date has been set [__]
so young Sheldon will end its run at CBS
with its upcoming season 7 The Big Bang
Theory prequel series is set to return
on February 15th with a 1H hour series
finale at set to air on May 16th the
season will be shorter than those before
due to the truncated nature of the 20123
2024 because of the SAG strike so it's
ending and we get a short season so
here's what the CBS Person said as a
prequel to one of the biggest comedies
young Sheldon proved lightning can
strike twice it set itself apart with a
remarkable cast that felt like a family
from the first moment we saw them on
screen and brought characters to life
with unique heartfelt stories that Drew
audiences in from the start we extend a
SE sincere thank you to the executive
producers Chuck lore Steve malaro and
Steve Holland and the entire writing and
producing teams for six wonderful
Seasons we look forward to seeing their
final season unfold and giving a proper
sendoff with the best episodes yet for
their fans to enjoy is it Lura or Lori I
don't know I only asked because she this
person saying uh we prove that we can
strike lightning in a batttle twice on
the same show like no Chuck lore or Lori
genius you know when his name is on
something like you know everyone on the
show is getting rich so good I mean
you're right we're being robbed because
not only is this precious show ending
yeah it's a shorter season due to a
strike so we're just screwed we're
screwed and if uh you don't watch Young
Sheldon and I'll go as far as to say you
don't watch The Big Bang Theory I don't
watch The Big Bang the and that's
because uh you for whatever reason have
this like pre ceive notion that these
aren't cool shows no The Big Bang Theory
is a show for losers no it's not and
it's a losery show and it's horrible
like even after I gotone to Young
Sheldon I give big bank I gave Big Bang
Theory another try I can't believe it's
one of the it's like as bigger than
Modern Family you never you never got
into it it's like the people that are
writing comments to us saying I watched
cuz we recently started Gossip Girl I'm
sure you've been talking about that with
them rewatching Gossip Girl people are
like I couldn't get through the first
three episodes they're so cringe like
yeah have you watched the Friends pilot
like if you if have you watch Seinfeld's
first episode like you need to give
these iconic shows at least a season or
two just to like let them like there's a
reason there's a reason these shows are
so popular no for sure but like saying
you need to give a show two seasons
before it gets good like well then we
can all just agree it's a bad show if
two seasons are unbearable so then not
before it gets good maybe start on
season two and Wikipedia what happened
in season one just cuz the acting gets
better these people get closer I just
have like no interest in Big Bang Theory
like none of the characters speak to me
none of the actors
me I just I don't like Big B but young
Sheldon really is which is better um
they're very different I think Young
Sheldon is a more well-rounded show it's
such a pure show Big Bang Theory is f is
funnier okay young Sheldon is is like
it's actually an amazing show it's one
of the best shows I've seen and the fact
that it is ending is obviously
devastating but the whole concept of the
show is that it's a prequel so it
couldn't go on forever because there's
another show at some point yeah and it's
about young Sheldon in the beginning the
first couple of seasons are the best
because the kid who plays young Sheldon
is maybe 8 years old he's the cutest kid
ever and he grows up and he gets to high
school and you know kids go through that
awkward stage and it's not like this
cute little young Sheldon anymore it's
like a grown you know pre-present te and
it definitely changes the the vibe of
the show it definitely does um but it's
about so much more than Sheldon his
grandma M his dad who would you say is
your favorite character
for me it's the dad George Cooper hands
down yeah between Mima and George Cooper
I don't know M's great too I can tell
you emphatically my least favorite
character is Mary Cooper and if I
disagree my least favorite character is
actually Sheldon oh
ah no look he the show is here because
of him but he's still that happens a lot
though right now right right now it's
not great with that is always what
happens with big shows the person who
the show is about Carrie Bradshaw is the
worst most insufferable character from
desv no no you're right that always
happens you're absolutely right I I tend
to be absolutely right I forgot to put
on underwear today you forgot to put
underwear yes wearing sweatpants without
underwear is like weird wow just sharing
so this is devastating yes RIP young
Sheldon but
I'm looking forward to the final season
I'm sure it'll be great I too am looking
forward and uh if you haven't watched it
you should really give it a try it was
probably but we also just got off the
nanny and we're doing Gossip Girl so
these these have all been great
rewatches and I did tell everyone on the
toast yesterday that you've never seen
the O I haven't no and that you
absolutely must oh somebody told me CU
we were talking about yesterday how we
think about the OC and we forget like
that because it's a show about like
these like rich kids who live in OC in
Orange County and the show is actually
very Jewish because the family that it
follows the coin are Jewish but you
don't think of it as like a Jewish show
like you would think think the Annie and
somebody pointed out that the Creator or
writer I think his name is Josh harwitz
of the OC actually eventually left the
OC and went to Gossip Girl because we
were watching Gossip Girl and there's so
many like Jewish references and Israel
references in a positive way and we were
like this is so Random even though it's
a show about New York and you know all
the Jews live in New York but I think
that's why because of that guy
interesting yeah by the way he needs to
we need to talk to him yeah know he's
he's great he a good show give me give
everyone like a quick what are your
thoughts on Gossip Girl I love it I've
always loved it though like I loved the
original watch and the rewatch though
like you're looking at this and you're
like I was really allowed to watch this
when I was 14 yeah with cocaine there's
like they're like blowing lines nuts and
it's like like following like these kids
as they're supposed to be 16 we were the
same age as them yeah it it definitely
was crazy to watch Gossip Girl in high
school thinking that this is what kids
did in high school crazy that said such
a good show they're all really great
great actors and
uh uh Blair Blair waler if is the best
character by far was it a part of your
high school experience cuz for
me where I went to high school is where
they filmed Gossip Girl they filmed in
the city all around the Upper East Side
and during like our free periods or
during lunch like on our blackberries
like there would be uh like people on
New York if they were filming like you
would find out instantly like you could
take your free period and literally part
of my life was following them around and
like hoping to see one of them coming
out of trailer did you do that not like
to the same extent but I do remember
that yes it was just like a part of
everyday life when we were in high
school it was it was and it definitely
fed into Blackberry BBM culture yes big
time did you have your BBM pin um
memorized I did yes I don't remember it
anymore though me neither but I did it
would be crazy if you remember it did
all right we have a little bit more TV
news tell me shocking Bobby Burke is
leaving query oh after season 8 so a
member of the Fab Five is saying goodbye
Bobby Burke is officially leaving the
Netflix series after season 8 the
designer who stars on the show alongside
car tan Anthony and Jonathan announced
on November 13th he said it's not been
an easy decision to be at peace to be at
peace with but it's a necessary one
although my journey with queery is over
my journey with you is not you will be
see seeing more of me very soon the love
that I've received from you all over the
last six years has been absolutely
surreal you have tuned in and been
dedicated fans and together we were able
to share the healing powers of design I
learned from you all about kindness love
and acceptance and that has changed my
life for the better long basically just
being like love you I'm out you know
there's a multitude of things going on
here I think everybody like is curious
like what's the tea I mean young Sheldon
only gets Seven Seasons but query gets
eight no it's by the way it's also crazy
CU like when query came out seasons one
and two like you remember the choke hold
it had us in we were like laying in bed
crying yeah and I feel like nobody
watches it anymore I definitely have not
watched it since season 2 right and I'm
surprised that they're on season 8 me
too but also what I'm surprised by is
there have been like rumors about some
of the guys not getting along and there
were like it's pretty much known that
kuramo and Anthony like really didn't
get along in the beginning like they
just did not they were just different
guys so the fact that bobb's the one
leaving is shocking now of course
everybody's making jokes Bobby was the
chef no Bobby is the one who literally
builds them houses why did I think he
was a chef Anthony is Chef is a chef I'm
sorry Bobby is the blonde one yes yes
yes yes who literally like on the
episode you know car takes him oh yeah
he's the one I remember he does all the
work but they don't ever show him no and
then he just they all just come up like
a brand new house yeah by the way I
would leave if I was Bobby too yeah
maybe he's tired totally of doing
everything but getting none of the air
time so true but also I kind of feel
like I could see Netflix giving him his
own design show totally yeah like that
would like he that's what he deserves
and I have to say I met Bobby literally
the nicest guy like I don't think
there's I don't think he's like a diva
who can't get along with people cuz I
met him at e like we were just in the
same green room and he was so nice and
he had no idea like who or what I was he
just thought I probably was like some
assistant wow really nice love it yeah
he should get his own show but I do
wonder if they're going to replace him
because I remember when they were
casting for queery a friend of mine
who's gay and a hairdresser in La was
like talking about the casting it is the
role of a lifetime like every gay hair
stylist interior designer Chef it's like
the dream job because you become really
like a cultural icon and it's one of the
most like the fact that anyone would
walk away from it is shocking to me
unless he had a opportunity because it
is the one of the best jobs in Hollywood
like you just become so famous so I
wonder if this means they're going to
replace him or they're no longer going
to be doing houses but the the thing
about queery in the original show it's
like it's a fab five there's always five
of them so I do think they're going to
replace him so who is like a
Fab gay interior designer but the thing
is are the Scot brothers are either of
them gay no good guess though um but the
thing is about the show is that nobody
knew these guys before the show so they
don't pluck famous people true true but
maybe like
a like an Instagram designer like I'm
trying to think sound up in the comments
who you think would be a good
replacement but this is shocking news
and I wonder if it's He he'll be the
first to fall yeah oh true it could be a
domino effect right down goes queer eye
down goes queer eye wow all right are
you ready for our next story this is a
story I've been keeping up with a lot
and like I'm shook by we talked about it
maybe two weeks ago the hockey incident
in the UK this has a choke hold on you
craziest day every night no it's
definitely crazy but every single night
Claud is like there's a there's a new
development in this uh guy who flung his
skate and I mean a guy died on the ice
nuts it was in the UK it was in the UK
and what was so crazy is that like I
guess nobody really me at least I never
put together that like there are blades
on your skates and you're not wearing
like a protector of your neck like I
never put that together I just assumed
like the hockey leagues would have
figured it out neck guards well like you
it's not a neck guard but like your
helmet does come down there isn't a lot
of room it's a very very bad freak
accident but like the the the skate
easily could have hit him in the face
right the fact that it was a neck but
there are neck guards that's like a a
part of a hockey equipment but they're
optional and they shouldn't be yeah
really dumb really dumb yeah so a man
has been arrested on suspicion of
Slaughter after the ice hockey player's
death authorities have released new
details on their investigation into the
death of Adam Johnson 2 weeks after the
ice hockey player was fatally injured
during a game a man has been arrested on
suspicion of manslaughter the South
Yorkshire police announced on November
14th the unnamed person remains in
custody wait who else would it be why
are they saying the man unnamed also the
South Yorkshire this happened in the UK
I'm saying S Johnson a member of the
British professional Club of the
Nottingham Panthers was playing in the
challenge Cup match at util utila Arena
Sheffield on October 28th when he
collided with a member of the opposing
team appearing to suffer an injury to
the neck the following day Johnson's
team shared that he' passed away
according to a November 14th press
release from authorities a postmortem
examination confirmed that the
29-year-old died as a result of the
Fatal neck injury our investigation
launched immediately following this
tragedy and we have been carrying out
our extensive inquiries ever since to
piece together the events which led to
the loss of Adam in these unprecedented
circumstances the detective Chief
superintendent said in the press release
we've been speaking with a highly
specialized expert in their field to
assist in our inquiries and continue to
work closely with the health and safety
department of the Sheffield City Council
which is supporting our ongoing
investigation
so I guess they haven't commented on who
was arrested but I think we can all
assume it's the other player the one who
put his skate in the guy's neck yeah
this is like so crazy cuz and I was
reading tweets and like a lot of people
think this was intentional that and I I
I don't it can't I I saw the video you
showed it to me this morning can't you
Google the video yeah because it's
really not that gruesome it's not
graphic but it's just crazy to see like
you see what's happening you see his leg
above above sure he went to kick him
which is [__] up when you're literally
wearing a knife on your foot yeah that
said if you kick him in the chest the
padding is nothing you kick him in the
helmet the padding's nothing like it
like it it doesn't it it's [__] up
it's not manslaughter no so a lot of
people think it's intentional and I
don't agree with that like I do think
this was like a really Reckless accident
I think he wanted to kick him or hurt
him but not kill him obviously but like
how do you reconcile that with the fact
that like somebody just lost their son
it's terrible and his family's been very
public there distraught over this like
it shouldn't have happened of course
they are but um not to victim blame you
got to wear the net guard but the thing
is when it's not made optional nobody
it's not like he wear everybody wear it
but but now they need to now but so now
this should be for the NHL for everybody
this really needs to be a a blade on
your foot it's insane it's insane that
it was optional or like your helmet
should literally be attached to your
shoulders like it should be one whole
thing there also needs or like some
better Tech like it doesn't need to be
so bulky like there's definitely like if
you think about um what's that like
wiring um not like chicken wire but like
something right it's like thin where if
you kick through it it doesn't break the
seal it's a terrible story it is it's a
terrible story he had a life partner
it's a terrible story so sad and like
honestly like just crazy I didn't know
something like this could happen yeah
it's it's funny I remember like we all
go ice skating as kids the the you do
think about that with the blade knif
it's like a knife and it's if it's not
like a knife you can't skate like it
needs to be a sharp as humanly possible
for you to glide on the ice why are we
sliding on knives like what's wrong with
rollerblades um you can't put roller
blades on Ice yeah you could just have
the floor yeah I understand but like
floor hockey no but instead of taking
away the blade I think you take away
like what we said no but like the fact
that this was even a sheer possibility
yeah is such a Shonda it has to have
happened before I don't think so I I do
and if immediate change doesn't like for
all leagues I know hockey's really big
in Canada in the NHL like everybody
should be looking towards this as a huge
red flag and they need now need to show
Blades of Glory in schools remember in
Blades of Glory I never seen it with the
the reason why I forget the name of the
trick you've never seen Blades of Glory
with Will frell you're lying M okay
figure skating movie unbelievable he
makes it to like the finals whatever and
this like incredible trick that nobody
has tried since this guy had his head
chopped off by a blade oh my God CU he
like spins in the air his blade is up he
like flips him yeah dead but obviously
will frell does unscathed of course um I
don't remember the name of the trickell
is so funny probably the funniest guy of
all time that's like such a crazy movie
he's a fingure skater no no he's he's
unbelievable yeah you're unbelievable
another movie that everybody should see
it's so funny I don't see like the
classics no Ben had never seen my these
are my Classics Ben had never seen my
cousin Vinnie up until recently okay I
had never seen my cousin Vinnie up until
like six years ago yeah when I found
that out and made you watch it that day
yeah great movie nobody to Glory but
okay you ready for our next story it's a
little sad news ready Freddy by the way
more sad than the person dying on the
ice well somebody did die oh wow morbid
show well we he didn't recently did well
he did it's not news Matthew Perry and
now some of the friends have come out
with their tributes and of course
everybody's just heartbroken So Courtney
Cox has shared a poignant tribute to
Matthew Perry after his death she shared
a tribute to her friend's co-star two
weeks after his shocking death she wrote
I'm so grateful for every moment I had
with you Maddie and I miss you every day
she included a clip of one of her
favorite friend scenes with Matthew
Perry from the season 4 finale in which
um Ross finds Monica and Chandler in bed
together to give a little backstory
Chandler and Monica were supposed to
have a one night fling in London but
because of the audience's reaction it
became the beginning of their love story
in this scene before we started rolling
he whispered a funny line for me to say
he often did things like that he was
funny and he was kind the actress who
noted that there are thousands of
moments she could revisit uploaded her
post just hours after Matt LeBlanc
became the first friends star to take to
social media since the loss so we've now
gotten tributes from Monica and from
Joey this is just like G stinks this is
just like one of the saddest stories
yeah it is and I don't believe it's
fully been confirmed how he
passed which
is crazy it is and I I was one of those
we spoke about this on good guys I was
one of those people that definitely
jumped the gun and said like of course
like an addict no l with addic must have
lost his battle with addiction I don't I
don't even know if that's true no by the
way it's not and I felt so bad after
saying that cuz it was just like a dumb
assumption for sure when he like I'm
actually reading his book for my book
club I haven't started it yet but I know
a lot of it is about of course his
journey to sobriety but also the work
that he did after he became sober he
opened up with his own money like all
these facilities for men struggling with
addiction like and so I hate that like I
assumed yeah especially not thinking
through again I don't want to like uh
guess is cause of death that's not like
a good use of time game to play yeah
exactly but um everybody knows that hot
tubs hot tubs are low-key dangerous
you're like you're like cooking your
body and if you if we if you had like
olympic size hot tub in your own house
you probably spend a lot of time in it
and like you're relaxed and you don't
realize how hot you're getting and you
overheat like I've gotten out of hot
tubs and felt lightheaded um I have
gotten out of a hot tub member yeah of
course I do and I literally like threw
up fainted yeah because you're cooking
your body at 104° for an extended period
of time and it is very plausible for one
to pass out and drown no and thank God
right I was in a house full of people
and you threw me in the pool yeah the
cold pool did yeah and I instantly felt
better but he was probably alone I think
yeah and the when I think about that it
makes the story 10 times sadder because
if he battled addiction his entire life
overcame it and then died in a freak
accident I mean regardless it's terrible
but it it's very it's very very very
very sad and hard and stinks so yeah so
I'm actually really excited to read his
book because I think it's a really good
combo of course he's like was at one
point in time the most famous person in
the country yeah and he dated Julia
Roberts and I'm sure has all these like
Amazing Friends stories and Hollywood
stories then there's also this like
really dark side of it where he said you
know he used to go you know pretend to
buy like a to be a prospective buyer and
go to open houses and go to people's
houses and steal their their
prescription pills like that's how bad
his addiction was so I think it's
probably a really good
combo in terms of like a book yeah it's
definitely I I would read it but if you
knew how to I can't read it so yeah
that's so sad I can't read all right you
ready for our Fifth Fifth and final
story a little Che crack whole news
ready Freddy So Courtney Kardashian and
Travis Barker are Making Waves um
because she was wishing Travis a happy
birthday on Instagram and she shared you
know picture some of this photo shoot
they had did I believe it was some sort
of pregnancy shoot and it's very NSFW
you know he's holding her titties that's
not really NSFW cuz like she's pregnant
it was really just meant to be like very
Rockery but also pregnant you know and
there were a few pictures that I think
caught the attention of a lot of people
and for me it was uh this one let me
show it to you and I'll show it to the
YouTube as well oh yeah so if you
haven't seen it it's Travis and Courtney
they're hugging each other so we see
Courtney's back and we see Travis
hugging her from the front and as he's
hugging her we see him with his hands
basically in her ass so this is a
conversation we actually had last week
about you know butt
touching and we came up with this little
limmer called cheek crack hole cuz if
you're going to be grabbing someone's
phot ass in a photo you know hand on the
cheek is obviously totally the best y
crack cuz we saw a video of Leonardo
DiCaprio's girlfriend like literally
putting her fingers in his crack it's a
little dirtier but it's not as bad as
whole now would you categorize this
photo of Travis and Courtney as cheek
crack or
hole the problem is I'm sure it was je
that said you cannot see his entire hand
it's giv so I have nothing to do nothing
to say but hole it's giving hole yeah it
has to be which according to you know
the toast is the worst type goes cheek
crack hole hole Yeah and uh I don't
think that hole hole is reserved for a
private place I would agree PO is
deserved for a privit place between you
know two consenting adults yes yes so
yes that is a that is an intense
photograph now should we and I wish them
well should we recreate these photos in
your opinion sure
but it's my hand yeah your hand okay so
we'll be going cheek we'll be going
cheek yeah we'll be going cheek yeah
yeah is nice yeah unless we get like uh
like charman sponsorship or like uh yeah
what's the or like a oh dude wipes call
me yeah yeah that's a good idea right
cheek crack crack
hole Yeah cheek crack
hole it kind of it's like a song if you
want it to be yeah it's pretty good yeah
cheat crack hole it s like Jimmy crack
horn Che crackn I don't care crack hole
and I don't care Che crack hole and I
don't care cheek crack hole and I don't
cheek crack hole and I don't care say
cheek crack hole five times fast cheek
crack hole cheek crack hole cheek crack
hole cheek crackle cheek crackle Che
crackle Che crackle C you pretty much
did it it's really not that hard and
those with the F 5 and the absolutely
amazing news is that we still have a
little bit of show left because it is
dear toasters our weekly advice segment
where people write in and we do our best
to get through as many as we can today
we'll do three submissions and let me
let you know that today's thr dear
toasters is brought to you by Pillsbury
after so your weeknight dinner rotation
is getting a glow up because of the new
simple recipes that you can make with
Pillsbury crescent rolls they can be
added to your week night dinner rotation
because we are so busy being mothers
Brothers Sisters Wives friends that
sometimes like it's just too much to
make a five course meal for dinner but
you want something filling you want
something delicious you want something
creative you want something that maybe
the picky eater in your life whether
it's a toddler or for Ben it's me you
want something that they'll enjoy it and
that's what's so great about Pillsbury
crescent rolls is that week night
recipes are as easy as fill roll bake
you can roll up your favorite
ingredients into a crescent roll it's a
quick and easy spin on a week night
recipe so you can get creative and come
up with one of your own like I think
none enough people are talking about
rolling up a peanut butter and jelly in
a crescent roll warming it up in the
oven like that's delicious but the
pillsberry website has a ton of
different recipes like pepperoni pizza
crescent rolls if you're a kosher girlly
just take the pepperoni out a little
sauce a little cheese chicken bacon
ranch crescent rolls ham and cheese
crescent rolls so you can go to the
website for inspiration or if you're
feeling creative like I feel like
crescent rolls are just one of those
things like throw some crap in it and
it's going to be good like for sure and
it's going to be filling it's going to
be delicious they're also just so good
on their own so you can find pillsberry
in the dairy aisle get dinner prep done
in 30 minutes or less and most
importantly it's picky eater pleasing so
someone like me or a toddler will be
happy with whatever you roll up so
Phil
roll bake with Pillsbury that you can
find in the dairy aisle and head to
pillsbury.com for recipe ideas today's
episode is also brought to you by
vegamore you have heard me talk about my
hair and scalp and how they've
transformed thanks to vegamore I never
thought I could see these kind of
results with a product that was made
with clean ingredients because I was
definitely doubtful of the whole clean
Beauty thing I'm not going to lie and
vegamore is the real deal and what's
great is that right now vegamore is
having their biggest sale of the year so
I'm stocking up on all my favorites I've
gotten a lot of questions about you know
since I lost a lot of weight I
experienced a lot of hair shedding and
thin
what did I do I did a bunch of things
and vegamore was one of them the grow
serum I love so with vegamore I'm able
to have visibly thicker fuller shinier
longer hair without all the harsh
ingredients every cute pink bottle of
vegamore products are 100% cruelty-free
And they are never formulated with
potentially harmful chemicals like
parabens or hormones what's even better
is that vegamore value kits like the
grow Essentials kit where you get to try
more than one amazing product at a great
savings yes so I bought the grow kit
because I wanted the grow serum and I
got the shampoo and conditioner and it's
fabulous so when you sign up for a
monthly subscription you save more and
you never run low on the products that
you need to take care of your hair the
key is consistently in your routine for
your most beautiful healthy looking hair
so if you stay in the subscription
you'll never run low and you just like
constantly be doing it constantly be
growing Vore grow de hair serum daily
and uh hair serum daily are keeping my
hair and scalp flourishing so for
limited time go to vore.com toast and
use code toast to check out to get in on
vegam More's biggest sales of the Year
during their Black Friday and Cyber
Monday that's v g m o ur.com toast code
toast to get the best deals on vegam
More's line of products vore.com toast
Cod toast today's episode is also
brought to you by roback active wear I
think it's safe to say that everyone is
talking about robach they just launched
their brand new jogger and Hoodie sets
and we cannot take them off they are so
soft so comfortable and just perfect for
the fall they use their vsoft Fabric and
the name says it all it's the soft
softest fabric we own whether you're
lounging around or having a casual day
out and about these jogger sets are for
you honestly shereé knew what she was
talking about when she said joggers for
fall like outfits that you can just
throw on and look put together but still
be comfortable like jogger sets roback
has the best ones I love them for
podcasting I love them for laying around
the house I also love them for you know
walking Theo leaving the house you still
look put together you can also just lay
around in them and the good news is is
that robach also has you covered for the
man in your life whether it's their
performance hoodies the polos or the
joggers it's all the men we know are
wearing so if you want your man looking
good then get him and rowack and with
fall right around the corner make sure
to check out roback use code toast on
roback for a generous 20% off your first
order of any fall essential robach is
spelled r h o b a c k and that's 20% off
with code toast on everything for
yourself and for the man in your life
check them out now I feel like for men
it's hard to like look comfortable
without looking schlubby and that's why
sets are so great the uh loungewear sets
from robach are amazing for the man in
your life but also for you and make sure
to use code toast at rhob bac.com you'll
get 20% off with code toast are you
ready for dear toasters ready all right
so if you guys ever want to write in
it's dear toasters gmail.com or you can
head to the toast podcast.com it's all
Anonymous
and we can help you okay this one's
funny hi swirlies I love my girlies and
the advice that you give others so when
this was brought to my attention I knew
I needed to turn to the turd and the
Jacks for help said for her she didn't
get tury and Jacks she got tury and BSC
so let me just say this straight I
cannot eat leftovers it's a long-term
phobia that I just can't explain this
year I'm hosting Thanksgiving and my
in-laws are driving 6 hours to visit I
recently learned that my mother-in-law
has already made stuffing and apple pie
over two weeks before Thanksgiving who
knows what else she'll bring in to a
whole ass cooked turkey I've been really
looking forward to both Thanksgiving
Staples and not to mention that I'm
pregnant but now I simply can't and I
simply sh is it rude to make or buy my
own day of or do I just not eat it what
would Jax and Claude do girl just buy an
extra pie cuz you can never Thanksgiving
is of those things you can never have
too much also look my mother-in-law
mother-in-law my mother-in-law bought a
pie oh but I also got one from Publix
like it's so not a big deal like like
Thanksgiving is Buffet that's true you
can always have extra food and by the
way I don't like leftovers either but
like sometimes I I will have you do like
leftovers I like chili leftovers certain
things you like all leftovers no certain
things I never take like food home from
a restaurant if no you like leftovers if
we ordered something in you will eat it
the next day depends on what it is I'm
very particular I'm very particular
but I don't think this has anything to
do with leftover somebody cooking
something two weeks in advance that's
disgusting I thought about it it's
actually not disgusting it's the same
exact way that you can freeze anything
and what she probably did because it's a
six-hour drive she probably made the pie
right froze it immediately and then took
the pie and the pie will still be frozen
by the time she gets there it's
definitely not like it's not going to be
a gray pie I'm not going to lie like the
the real problem here is that your
mother is cooking you [__] food if
you're making it 2 weeks in advance it's
just un it's just unnecessary what pie
is worth all that trouble when literally
store-bought pie and not even like a
fancy Publix's pie like so good you heat
it up in the oven there's literally no
reason you should ever make a pie I
stand by what I said no so you can make
a pie that I totally disagree with
especially as a celebrity chef we need
to make our own pies that said uh the
amount of grief that you are going to
get from this mother-in-law not only
driving six hours but making you a twoe
pie and you're not going to like the pie
good freaking luck Lady by the way no
how many people are coming to your
Thanksgiving like is she going to be
watching what you eat also you're
pregnant anybody who attacks a pregnant
woman period I miss that part or for
what she eats Straight to Hell totally
straight to hell and just like figure
out what type of pie it is and say that
like it's just revolting you as a
pregnant woman like you can't do apples
anymore right that's like an easy
excuse I'm sorry I was reading this to
your toasters and it's really crazy go
hey girlies I need your help I oh just
back to that girl like eat whatever the
[__] you want yeah I need your help I've
been dating a guy for 6 months he's been
a total P jom we are in love and things
have been getting really serious but I
snooped through his phone recently and
I'm shook [__] around and find out early
in our relationship he bought me five
sets of lingerie which I thought was so
sweet and a very sexy gesture well after
looking through the photos in his phone
I found out that a girl he dated shortly
before me was the one he bought those
for tons of picks of her in the exact
same lerie I'm assuming he didn't
repurchase these for me and I've been
wearing her stuff but either way I got
the ick also why are these photos still
on his phone what do I do not you like
sharing vagina pads with this girl like
that's so unsanitary I doubt he watched
them by way I it's impossible to they're
the same he didn't break up with a girl
and say give me my lingerie back oh
that's true I'm confident that it's
different he just is a creep for sure
but not the level of creep that maybe
you think he is these are this is new
lingerie it has to be by the
way that's a very good point he wouldn't
ask for the lingerie back no that's
disgusting yeah but maybe he it went
over so well with the first girl yeah
yeah maybe it was just she really liked
it she found it sexy he thought that you
would really like it you'd find it sexy
why does he still why does he still have
it on his phone right the fact that he
copied the same gift isn't a crime like
it's just men being unoriginal but where
I think the problem lies within the
photo still being on the phone yeah but
also how old are these photos like how
recent is this we're again missing
information how old is this how did you
find them like to be honest if you're
snooping back seven years and you find
something that's on you yeah like like
I'm sorry that's why you shouldn't Snoop
like you're never going to find
something that's going to make you happy
you shouldn't Snoop you shouldn't Snoop
agreed but you did so now what do we do
with this information that's the lesson
here for next time but to to address
this current situation now you certainly
confront and you make sure that yes
you're not sharing vagina to vagina uh
lingerie just to make sure that you're
not getting some disease from this ex
you have to admit that you snooped yeah
sorry I snooped that said what I found
trumps the punishment for snooping and
you need to explain yourself yeah now
I've made myself sick so you don't even
have to punish me cuz I know I was wrong
but do confirm that these aren't the
same exact panties because that's
literally one of the most disgusting
things I've ever heard in my life and
then also just be like oh and why do you
still have these photos yeah You' got
yourself into this situation and I'm
afraid you're going to have to get
yourself out because you really can't
ignore this yeah know it's it's
definitely strange yeah it's definitely
strange but I feel like you he could exp
this doesn't sound like a crazy red flag
to me I think he could explain his way
out of this where it would make sense
and he's not a bad bad guy yeah it's
just like I don't know maybe I'm just
like so not the lingerie buying type no
you've never bought me lingerie you've
never bought me
underwear actually not true you have
yeah you want me to buy you undies no
undies are very personal that's what I'm
saying how do you buy somebody like it
it's just strange me because lingerie is
not like underwear you are to work oh
you're saying that if I bought you
lingerie that's not like buying undies
no no it's different like if that's like
what you wear for SE for like sexy time
yeah but like that's why I bought you
your original SK skeleton pajamas from
Target and that's why I love you isn't
that our version of lingerie yes yeah
see and that way like I'm by the way I
would never ever ever hypothetically
speaking if I had dated somebody else I
would never buy the same pair of pajamas
for the two it's personal thank you by
the
way please stop talking about you dating
other people like that's pville USI I
know I'm sorry all right are you ready
for our fifth third and final deer
toasters yes yes yes hey gorgeous
girlies I'm a longtime toaster OG bre I
live in New York City with my fiance say
he is a total preum my parents still
live in the childhood home in
Connecticut and that I grew up in and
while having lunch with them this past
weekend they told me that they are
leaving me the house and they plan to
move in the next 5 years the house is
totally paid off everything like that
obviously this made me so excited the
idea of living in my childhood home is
so cozy to me but also a house in this
economy Nob brainer but my fiance says
he would feel weird about living in the
house because it won't feel like ours he
thinks we should buy our own house when
the moment comes am I crazy to be
annoyed at this and think what are you
nuts please help a girl convince him
it's an amazing thing and get excited
your fiance unless he's a Rockefeller is
a [__] [__] yeah do you know how
many young couples starting out in their
life would literally kill to get a house
and not starting in Connecticut and not
starting on I'll take the house I'll
take the house at any let me take the
house what a gift your parents have
given you my God Beyonce is an idiot
yeah he's definitely an idiot uh huge
red flag um yeah unless he comes for
major money and and money isn't an
option here no it doesn't sound that way
and what I can say as a stubborn man who
has moved begrudgingly
before you'll fall in love with the
house because men when did you move
begrudgingly not begrudgingly but like
there have been like our our last house
I didn't love as much as you true and
then when we got there and we got into
it and we made it ours I loved it this
current apartment we both felt was
unbelievable from the second we got
there I understand what you're saying
that's rare right it's rare uh take the
house the guy's going to end up loving
it he's going to make it his his own and
if you don't love it in 5 years you can
always sell the house no of course but
like first of all you should not sell a
house that's completely paid off like
then what you oh I'm with you then you
have to go and move to another house and
by the way this is the house that your
parents lived in their whole lives so
it's not a starter house no it's
probably a big house yeah they raised
all their kids there yeah and the think
of all the money you would put down on a
down payment on real estate taxes fees
all right so it's not your own you'll
make it your own put some Renovations in
spend the money like are you are you
okay or honestly maybe he just needs to
hear an outside perspective maybe play
this episode for him and let me speak
directly to him hey
fiance love you you're [__] take this
house what a gift you've been given like
do you know how many people like buying
a house the mortgage every month it
weighs on them so heavily it affects
their daily lives you've been given a
gift and probably conservatively knowing
that it's in Connecticut oh yeah it
can't be less than a few million dollar
gift I I would say the average home in
Connecticut a million dollar I probably
$2 million depends on the neighborhood
probably $2 million regardless if
somebody came and gave you $700 Grand
right no and let me speak directly to
the girl you say no let me speak
directly to the girl who wrote in do not
let your fiance sway this decision like
this is an nons swayable decision like
my God it's not honestly take the house
over the man always it's an unsayable
decision thank you to everyone who wrote
into dear toasters our weekly advice
segment where every Wednesday we do our
best to help the girlies in need you can
write us at Deer toasters gmail.com or
head over to the toast podcast.com
there's a little submission box there
it's totally Anonymous and if we've
written in if you've written in and
we've read your queries on air and you
have an update for us let us know what
happened did you take our advice did you
not did you wish you did did you wish
you didn't it's like beyond the tank
exactly and that's our show Ben thank
you for making the time on such you know
late notice we really appreciate you
anytime always here make sure to listen
to the good guys podcast make sure to
follow Ben on Instagram at booy withth
no job and thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
life stories you need to know every M
through Friday so if you're watching us
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give us video
a thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcast can be found on
Spotify public radio rast box all places
we love you to podcast find to five view
but a Beau standing and wickedly
talented we are have an amazing hump day
and we'll see you tomorrow
t